how are you doing today sir
this is the beginning thanks for asking
i'm good despite everything i am good
i'm healthy and my family is well
and we're managing it's eight months
into this thing
um but the best i can say is i'm i'm
good
uh i've been asking these next few
questions of everyone i've been talking
to
um for the last six months or a year uh
what tv series would you love to guest
star on
i've really enjoyed succession i don't
know i'm really
loving that show uh so i wouldn't have
any problem at all getting on on guest
starring on that show that's
a great show and some of the writing is
of the highest quality
i completely agree um what
what movie do you think you've seen the
most oh
trading places i probably have watched
that movie more than any other movie
because i've got turned to that whenever
i'm feeling blue
that's just one of the best movies ever
made and if you haven't seen it it's a
crime not to see it
it's a christmas movie too uh do you
remember your first movie or tv show
crush
really good question um jenny agata
in uh railway children wow
i was a kid too and uh she i thought she
was the
cutest thing that ever walked um
i have a lot of different things i want
to talk about with you but i'm going to
start with the
the game of thrones um you were part of
the show for
uh a little bit but you joined i believe
in season
five and at that point the show was
enjoying worldwide success it had become
the juggernaut by season five
what was it like joining something like
that um
because i i'm very curious what it was
like joining a show like that
yeah it's interesting because it's um
it's weird
it's like uh coming into to a a football
team
uh to as a special k you know specials
team
kicker for the and and the team is
already a roaring success but you're
only there to punt goals
and um i i you feel very much on the
outside and
you and you have to rely on the grace of
the cast to
talk to you because they're already so
far above your station um and
sweetly they did they were very sweet
the ones i met were really nice
um so but it was it was a it's a very co
you're on in the cold and you know the
show is doing well and you know you had
nothing to do with it
and you're just getting on to something
that you've already you're benefiting
from the hard work of other people
what was it like um obviously you've
worked on many different things
how was uh game of thrones possibly
different in terms of did you get all
your scripts in advance
were there a lot of changes on the fly
there were no changes actually it was a
very unusual there was it was a well it
felt like a slightly too well oiled
machine
it was so perfect that uh
that it was kind of like i got me a
little bit suspicious because everything
else you know
we screwed up that line and we didn't
get this right and this scene isn't
gonna work and
you discuss it with the director but
this was there was none of that it was
like this is
perfect this will work and i'm sure they
were right
and so i just said my lines and left
go back to my hotel um there was none of
the usual
horse trading with with the director um
partly because the producers were on set
and they were senior to the director so
the director had to ask the
producers if someone could change a word
and the producers would come down and go
where
no or yeah well whatever way it worked
um they were all very nice don't get me
wrong they weren't like unpleasant or
anything but it was a very strict
hierarchy and they were on set
all the time and um it was it was
interesting that they felt
and they were right to feel that they
were doing me an enormous favor by
letting me on the show
and uh so i behaved i did i did my best
to try and have like that special team
kicker that
turns out one day because the other
guy's sick once you were off the series
did you continue watching
or were you uh were you heavily invested
in the series
i loved the series and i i watched it
all back to from you know back from
up to the season moment i came on and
then the moment i came on i
i stopped watching the moment i that was
the end so
i didn't watch anymore and i didn't even
watch the last season my wife watched it
all
um and but that was the thing she did
with a friend
and not me so it was i just stopped
partly because i knew it was happening
and i got
i'd seen the scripts and knew where we
were going what was
going to happen at least with the
seasons that i was involved with
um and so nothing new to me
but mainly because i don't like watching
myself on screen which i do do
you know like i've watched skylines the
show that is about to come out
because we're doing all these online
interviews
but i didn't do it with game of thrones
because it's um
yeah i'm it's game of thrones and then
i'm in the in the scene and who is that
and well my hair doesn't look great or
my nose looks funny and i just can't
concentrate
on on the show itself and it would
happen to anyone else to i betcha
uh jumping into that's the reason i get
to talk to you today skylines um
it's really funny to me that this is
essentially the second sequel it's the
third movie
in this franchise and all these
different
movies and all these different producers
talk about how they want to make
you know they're talking about a sequel
or they're thinking about doing a sequel
and they never materialize and yet this
franchise
is now on its third movie
what the i mean for me it's like wow
um so what what do you think it is about
this world
and these characters that has generated
three movies
i know it's astonishing and i think
mainly one of the most important things
is
they've done it on they've been so
clever doing it on a budget you know
they haven't risked millions of
investment dollars and the studios
haven't gone out of their way to put up
a big tent marquee movie
they've done it modestly um had a
total nerdy passion for for the sub for
the for the
genre and um that i think that's what
shows i think that's what at least the
one i've seen because i haven't seen one
and two
and i'll be honest but i you know i just
haven't seen one of two
um but i saw three and
i thought it was really cool and what i
really liked about it was its
canonical nerdiness its attention to
detail and the way it does
approaches sci-fi which is kind of
tongue-in-cheek which a lot of the next
generation
was like especially episodes with q
and then it was um but still you know
really slavishly devoted to high
um adrenaline action scenes
and um really cool martial arts uh
fights
um and i just thought it was great and
if you pan out if you come right up and
have a look you can even see
some social issues if you want to
discuss social issues if you feel like
it
but most people like to feel that leave
their brain at the door when they uh
you know sit down and watch a movie that
they know is meant to be entertaining
and this one delivers i think and it um
but if you do want to you know scratch
the surface you can talk about
all sorts of gender issues and uh you
know
autocracies that are happening around
the world and bad men
you know it does a good job on a lot of
different fronts i love it i
really enjoyed it and i happy to say
that too
i think that the uh one of the things
that sci-fi does so well
is being able to talk about other things
uh under the umbrella of maybe the
audience isn't realizing
what they're being taught you know what
i mean like it's there's a lot of
subtext to sci-fi
you're so right and and you're you're
particularly right because
it i i do i might disagree the audience
doesn't realize i think they do
but it's palatable it's not like their
neighbor
it's not like that guy's a republican
and that guy's a democrat
it's just taken out of context and that
makes it
so much easier um to discuss it because
i think
anybody would object to the way trump
behaves
if he wasn't trump if he was an alien
people like that guy's an [ __ ]
you know but because they've seen him on
tv
and he's a celebrity um that scrubs away
all the wrinkles and unpleasantness of
him people just admire his celebrity so
it's it's funny how celebrity elevates
people
and from in my own case and i haven't
said this before but
i think celebrity cleans color
you know it stops you being brown or
white or black
people just go oh i know you
um which is kind of an interesting thing
what would you get what was it like
making the movie behind the scenes
because as you said
this is not some 100 million dollar
movie this is being
made with like you know uh some duct
tape and
some you know uh director prime moving
lights
i mean i'm joking but not really you're
right
and so what i'm saying is what was it
like behind the scenes making this
it was i mean when i mean i've made a
lot a lot a few
low very low budget movies and low
budget films um
and this was definitely in the low
budget range it's not very low when they
had some money they built sets
uh they had a crew full crew um
so they kind of been poverty-stricken
but um when you're working on the lower
budget stuff
everybody has to work harder everybody
has to do more
you know you have to bring more to the
table than just turn up
glistening white smile and kiss the girl
and
you know cut you have to prepare to
work those action scenes again and again
because we haven't got enough cameras
and we
and we're not sure and if you get
something wrong you have to go go back
it's not going to be dealt with in the
edit and
you know all this stuff is really
interesting and physical sets you know
you can't do it's not all going to be
special effects you don't get to act
with a you know ping pong ball and a
green cross on a
thing on a fuzzy stick you actually have
to
do the scene on a set um and when you
get hit by something you all have to
shake
you know when when you get something
and it's pretty great it's it's old
school and the
the movie is a very old school style
film
it's the sort of film you haven't seen
you know since
way back when and um a lot of youngsters
today won't even have seen the film
is of this genre the kind of
tongue-in-cheek glam rock version of a
sci-fi movie
it's not aliens and it's that's too dark
and realistic this is
kind of aliens ghost to the fun faire
uh i want to switch uh into another
subject because i
i think uh ridley scott's kingdom of
heaven the director's cut
not the theatrical cut is a masterpiece
i love that movie
it is i can't say enough good things
about that film
you were obviously in the film uh what
was it like
what can you share about making that
movie and
what was it like for you because the
theatrical cut is missing
so much it's like it's it's painful when
you compare it to the longer cut
yeah i don't know why that is the case
really i must have had final cut
even with the studio version i mean i
can't imagine the director of his
stature not having final cut
but you're right the studio cut was just
appalling it was like a bad trailer for
a movie
which just depicted characters all
completely upside down and wrong he
didn't know who anybody really was in
their relationship to each other
but by the but the director's cut which
we filmed so that's all i knew
because that's the script that i had uh
monahan's script
um was fantastic and rich and
with wonderful performances especially
evergreen i think
just knocked it out the park um
and and there was a there was some i
mean it was
a fantastic experience it's one of my
most treasured sentimentally
moving experiences apart from the
worship ridley scott
you know who didn't my generation who
doesn't worship ricky scott
um brought up on blade runner and the
dualists
and thelma and louise and you go wow i'm
gonna do a movie with this guy
um and he was he delivered you know he
was effing and blinding
he's such a foul mouth on set that the
minute he's offset he turns into this
retiring shy little mouse and you go
is that the same guy who was calling
everyone the c word two minutes ago
yes it is and this time you can barely
smile
um great experience wonder wonder
wonderful experience
and i'd do that again in a heartbeat i
was lucky to do that when i was as young
as i was uh
i spoke to ridley about kingdom a few
times and he said that
it was the biggest mistake of his career
allowing the shorter cut to be released
i think the studio gave him feedback as
like you know
at the time those longer movies were not
performing
and i think that they convinced him to
release the shorter version
which really damaged that film it did
and it damaged it forever
i mean now it's not a great anymore and
and had it been the first cut had come
out
it would be a great you know i mean it's
better than dances with wolves and
that's a great
it's a classic uh and this
it was a shame but really i don't think
he'll mind me saying this
well he might um but he's not gonna give
me many more jobs now
um no offense um
he's deeply insecure and he just
he was deeply insecure about his cut his
edit what his film is like
and he it was said that he would
get anybody to see it just to get an
opinion before it was
even cut so you mix that in into the bag
this astonishing genius of a filmmaker
who happens to be deeply insecure about
his work
you end up with total screw-ups like
like that
yeah i'll just say for anyone who has
never seen king kevin
watch the director's cut it was my
favorite film of that year
it's just such a phenomenal movie um but
anyway i got to move on to other stuff
with you because i got limited time
and listen i i am and the fad who is
recording this right now we're both
huge star trek deep space nine fans and
i am definitely going to talk to you
about it because
i mean the show is amazing um so i want
to jump in
um who do you think would be better to
be stuck who's the better friend to be
stuck with
in a dangerous situation uh miles or
garrick
oh miles
[Laughter]
instant answer um garrick and i would
probably both have trouble dealing with
any serious problem
um certainly if it got physical mars
would just you know
people he could just raise his voice and
people like uh i guess we're out of here
okay so that's an easy one uh
what the thing about deep space nine is
it's the show went off the air over 20
years ago
and people like me and i'm sure many
others still want to talk about it
what what was it about this series that
um
that has people still wanting to talk
about it 20 years later
you know um i think that even confuses
the producers the the people who
actually
wrote the show that but i suspect apart
from the fact that it was
full of lovely characters really
interesting characters
it was true and it and that truth
rings out and you know i love the next
generation i was a huge fan of that show
even before i did deep space nine i went
down to blockbusters and rented those
videos and i had to schlep it
15 minutes on foot there and back again
to get two episodes and i watched them
back
back to back and i watched them again
the next morning when i woke up and then
i'd had to give them back to
blockbusters
so i loved that show but it wasn't true
you know it was just
it wasn't it was entertaining which is
what i loved about it but it didn't deal
with truth in the same sense
deep space nine dealt with truth it was
a soap opera in that
sense and these are real people doing
stuff that is sci-fi
and i think people really respond to the
reality um
even though it's in a sci-fi context um
that's my guess i mean i don't i'm not
an expert on tv
if it stretches the imagination i'm just
in it but
i think people love that they it just
doesn't change the truth
so every year 20 years later 30 years
later it's still oh yeah that makes
sense yeah
oh gosh yeah we're still like that oh
yeah i've got a friend like that
uh when did you first realize when you
were making the series
that so many people were responding to
the bashir garrick relationship
we didn't we didn't realize all we were
told every day you know
was that this show isn't doing very well
this show isn't doing well we've got to
figure out a way to make this show
better this show isn't this
it's shows sucking guys how do we how do
we compete with next generation next
generation so much better
voyages so much better they're doing so
much better than you so we got that
every goddamn day from the studio it
felt like
and uh the producers certainly felt that
but on the on the bright side
they left us alone studio couldn't care
less what we did you know
as long as we didn't overspend they just
going well go go enjoy have fun so ira
just went to town
with whatever he wanted to do i remember
the produce the executive producer
after michael pillow who was the first
person who ran the show who
sadly died um and uh we were lucky
because we were that we were kind of
despised
uh by the studio um so we didn't i
didn't know what
the people were responding to anything
with between myself and andy
um we loved doing our stuff we loved our
relationship we loved doing our schtick
um but we had no inkling about that this
i think that has
happened since to be honest i think that
that
now with people being more expressive
about their identity and
being gay being okay finally and you
know all those sort of things
that has lent real credence to the
bashir relationship because
obviously there was a in
i would say implied intimacy but not
intimacy no
more love between them you directed
actually two episodes of ds9
yeah and i'm curious when did you have
any pick
in the episodes or were they sort of
like okay here's your script here's your
script
and i was lucky enough to have armin
um but they're both uh ferengi episodes
and one was a pretty decent episode and
the second one was
one of the worst episodes that ever star
trek deep space nine had ever aired
um and that was partly because i became
cocky you know the first episode i was
really diligent
i was a director by heart i knew i knew
what i wanted in the second episode
i just the first episode i did
everything by the book i knew what they
wanted and how they wanted it and i did
it
and i think i was told by rick the head
producer this is the best debut
show we've done so i'm really thankful
so they're happy to give me another one
and the second one i did such a poor job
that uh they said you know what we don't
want you to do another one ever
this is terrible and that was called
profit and lace
and that was because i was like well
what if we turn this on his head
and how about this and what if i try
this
and they couldn't handle that at all
they don't do that on star trek
did you think at the end of every season
that you were definitely coming back
or were you always nervous every season
[ __ ] we might get cancelled
we were nervous about the cancellation
for the first two seasons
that's two and three hiatus between two
and three
but after that we got word that we're
going for the full six
and we better prepare for seven because
apart from anything else the franchise
couldn't afford to to
disown a show to cancel a show they so
much invested
around the show with the merchandise and
all the publicity and all that stuff to
admit to a failure
wouldn't have been good a good tactic
for the studio so they kind of
didn't give us astronomical budgets but
they said you go ahead
you're fine um and i think that was the
reason i'm putting words in
studio executives my mouth here because
i don't know that for a fact but
my guess is that they couldn't afford to
have a bad star trek at that point
because they wanted to roll
they were opening they started a network
um
on the back of voyager and uh
they just couldn't afford things to go
wrong so leave to dip deep space nine
going it sucks but hey no one watches it
and um we'll concentrate on you know
voyager and the good stuff and
and so we lucked out we got to keep i
think there was a show eventually got
cancelled but that
you know that's a massive climb down for
the studio for that to happen
um the thing about ds9 that a lot of
people don't realize
is that like you look at the shows today
that do 8 10
13 episodes and it's a lot of work
you guys did 26 episodes a season
i think from season two to season seven
i could be wrong but i think it's those
all those years um i don't think people
realize the
the what that is like behind the scenes
with trying to do 26 episodes a season
can you sort of talk a little bit about
that because the amount of work
i know a little bit about it i mean you
need because i directed as well so
i get i got to see the sausage factory
um and not just the sausage
and it just requires enormous amounts of
organization all the way along the line
so there would be two directors of
photography
uh who would hand off one to the other
two first
first assistant directors who would hand
off one to the other obviously a
different director for every show
so basically you had the same crew um
filming the show practically and then a
different director creative team
working on the next show and you have
exactly seven or eight days to work on
those shows
um and you better be ready by the time
they fire the gun because
once they they say right next show new
show everybody
and that would happen halfway through a
day sometimes um
then the new director would come in and
we'd just pretend to start all over
again hi nice to meet you who are you
and this is great i'm bashir i
played the doctor oh you're great so
that would happen every seven days
working days but it was an efficient
machine we have don't forget that we're
working in paramount studios
and we're working and that's got all the
equipment in the world
um which they paid a fortune for by the
way and
um then we have three sound stages uh
you know that's more than singing in the
rain god
and uh we so we have the the
vast empire of the one of the most
powerful studios in
in the world um what we couldn't afford
to do is go very far
so you know if you want to shoot
something that requires actual outdoor
territory
you better be there and back in an hour
because if you're wasting any more time
than that then
the show's screwed you can't just go to
south africa
do some stuff and come back so it was an
incredibly well-oiled machine
and we weren't the crew were the ones
that really had to do the hard work the
actors don't
work very hard you know we i might work
three days in a week
um because i've only got to i come in
and say you know
you're fine and then sometimes
i'd work all every day and i've got to
learn how hard it was for the
for the crew who were there every day
and you know we lost
um sadly lost two members of the crew
and one of them to just driving home too
tired at night and that's when they
went right there's no we're not working
any more than 12 hours a day
because this is getting ridiculous
because we used to work 16 we worked 22
hours for the in the pilot
one day and it just it's not the act
people think the actors are having a
hard time because you know we're the
ones on screen with this crew
they don't get to see their kids um and
in some cases
ever again so we that that was the
toughest thing about
it is is knowing the crew are going
through hell and so we did a thing which
was really cool and i don't i didn't
invent it i can't take credit for it i
just was one of the people who helped
is that we would every three or four
shows one of the actors
would do something fun for a day for the
crew
and at that time because starbucks was a
pretty new thing
and everyone was like starbucks if you
tried starbucks we'd
rent a starbucks trolley to come and
give free coffee all day to anyone who
wanted it whatever kind of coffee they
wanted and you know those kiosks you get
in the airports
we had one of those turn up on set every
now and then and people
love that because it was like oh
goodness coffee on tap
mocha on tap iced latte on tap um
that was fun so they they worked hard
but you should that's a question you
should get one of the crew guys one day
or
like a panel of them to come and tell
you what they thought yeah
well i mean i think the issue with the
crew working long hours hasn't changed
in any part of the movie or television
industry because
i just think that a lot of people don't
realize what it really takes to create
the entertainment that you enjoy at home
you know it's it's just really long
hours
yeah and people literally give their
lives i mean you know people
actually die and of course they die in
every job
so i'm not saying this is unique to to
people just die unfortunately
but um that it's brutal brutal for them
and their job is so precarious
it's not like us i could do something
awful but they couldn't get rid of me
and you've heard that you know you've
heard this actor on cocaine and that
actor you know
you'd have to basically abuse someone
molest someone to get fired
um you can't you can do just about
anything else
because you're so precious to the
franchise one of the things that ds9 did
before um any other star trek show and
before a lot of television shows is you
guys had a steer
a serialized story line uh well before
a lot of other people um when did you
realize that the serialized storyline
was going to be such a part of the
series did you know that early on or did
they sort of
sneak that in they snuck it in i mean we
didn't i certainly
i didn't i can't speak for everybody
else but i didn't realize it was
serialized until
you know season two uh i would say that
i was like hey wait a minute
that is familiar that and that
this is a theme um and it just began to
sink in because
i didn't know serialized tv myself i'd
seen
the next generation and various other tv
shows and they
are all standalone designed to be
syndicated it's designed to be shown in
any order
just in case people miss six weeks they
can watch this one and they just
pick up no problem but d space nine was
the first one that went no
you gotta watch it in order if you wanna
get the full
experience of this show he experienced
this
um and that was about season two i think
ira
knew he was going to do it somewhere in
the first season maybe halfway through
have you watched picard season one
because
there's a lot of other star trek actors
that have shown up and
obviously with the pandemic i don't know
if they're filming season two right now
but um you know a lot of people have
wondered if maybe you would show up you
could be
uh you know bashir is leading section 31
there's a lot of
possibilities here is it something
that's even crossed your mind
it hasn't and i haven't seen it i'm
really sad to say
and the reason i haven't seen it is that
i just have to
we had to put an end to buying new tv
channels
that i just you know everybody families
must be going you know how do we do this
there's hulu and there's this and now
cbs and then there's nbc and i know that
you know the channels we like said you
should not be saying this but
people keep your money we're in the
middle of a crisis
don't spend money on tv you'll be
spending 600 bucks a month before you
know it
an apple who charges by the show my wife
bought me an ipad for for my for
my birthday and it was because my last
one just couldn't stop touching itself
which is really weird and i know there's
an innuendo there
and it it really wasn't cool my advice
to be touching itself
in the corner so it was just switching
on it phoned somebody one day
and i was like what um so it's basically
dead so i got a new ipad and
um it came with a year's free apple tv
so i went wow
so i went in there and i went apple tv
and they said you want to see
mandalorian i said yeah i'll see
mandalorian
i clicked on that and he said you've got
to buy disney
you have to be kidding me you're giving
me a free years tv and i still can't
watch
tv but i can watch other stuff i guess
for the apple
channel whatever that is but i haven't
figured that out yet yeah i know i'm
just about out of time with you but i
have to touch on something which i think
is really cool
um you and andrew have been doing
essentially bringing fan fiction
to life and um which i think is amazing
and so unusual and so cool
so talk a little bit about the fact that
you guys what you've been doing during
the pandemic
and where people can watch it well mel
uh melissa lowry and and i um through
this
my fan club called sid city which i
didn't make up that name by the way i
don't know
um but we've been going for nearly 30
years 25 years
uh we went what are we gonna do and
covet and we said well let's talk to
people let's get a social club together
let's find out about
people's lives and then of course we did
that and we've been doing it for eight
eight months now um twice a week four
hours
and um at some point we i was talking
with a friend of mine who's a
good writer um and he said well i'll
write some stuff and
i've been writing fan fiction for years
i said sure give us it so we did four
episodes of
stuff and andy kindly agreed to do it
and uh it started off as just andy and
garrick and beshear but then
you know kira came in and then we got
quark involved and jake cisco was
involved right from the get-go so now
we've got
a kind of ensemble all doing this fan
fiction it's like a
fan fan's dream come true but it
actually has been really lovely and
people
really enjoyed it so we're doing it
again we're doing it right now and you
can
get there on you can go to sid city it's
um
we have room for 300 people so if
there's no if there's more than that
sorry um we can't post these on the
internet afterwards
like we did the first ones yet we're
negotiating posting them so if you do
miss it
we will hopefully have them online on
youtube at some point
and we're just continuing you know the
stories that people loved
um but this time written by fans who
love the stories
that's so interesting is it a thing
because i know paramount is very strict
with star trek and with um
anything that the fans create even
though it's actors from the series
is it something where you're running
into like the legal issues no
uh and we we would you know we had a
hard link from
from trek online so that was a that's
run by cbs
and uh so they i i believe that they
too in their in the in their wisdom
don't want to
put the dampers on fan fiction fan
fiction is a wonderful thing for star
trek it's such a symbiotic relationship
with the whole show
but also they know it's covet and they
know no one's making money
they know we're all taking time out to
do it and we're not doing
it with sets so don't expect to see
fancy sets or you know
have wonderful sound effects on it's
just readings it's just it's a radio
play
it's basically but you're seeing some
faces without makeup
we all look like yeah and
fill in the blanks and uh no one cares
you know we're just so we're just
reading it basically
so i think that they're going because i
know that they know but i think they've
got they're not
we're not we're not going to get into it
because we don't want to ask them so
they don't have to say no
um we're we we've put it out there
they have had months to respond but i
think they know this is a difficult time
and people could do with a pick-me-up
and it's not hurting
anybody the show it's not we're not
doing it's so canonical
it's so correct that um i think it can
only be a good thing and i hope they'd
agree yeah but listen
in all seriousness it is great to talk
with you and
um i think i speak for a lot of people i
know i speak for thad and myself
uh ds9 meant a lot to me and you know
i'm just saying that i'm
you know thank you for all your work
thank you and i'm glad to hear it